[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sixth of Wealsun, probably around 10 p.m. and 15 minutes, the party runs into the darkness up the hill.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tyrus lagging behind his compatriots who, as the minute arms begin moving up the path, they basically fire cover shots at them.
[SPEAKER_03]: The shield wall holds, no arrows really get through, but it dissuades them from pursuing you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Merrick, you begin leading the party up into the paths and trail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where do you want to go?
[SPEAKER_04]: Can you give me a little, I'll look around, can you give me a little, what we look like here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just want to know what's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're running.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's take this away.
[SPEAKER_02]: So here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_02]: The island where you're at
[SPEAKER_02]: It's kind of like this, it's not that blocky actually.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's more of a peninsula on this side.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is kind of where the beach is.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there are rocks over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is where the lighthouse is, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys were right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a path that goes up this way.
[SPEAKER_02]: To the lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_02]: This side is rocky.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the rocky place where basically it's the wall that lets all the other soil come here.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are scrubs
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, low trees in this area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kind of like Manzanita, but on the coastline and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Over here, too, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Up here, off the beach, there is some city.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mostly, the population seems to lie along that.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is wilderness, in a way.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are trees.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nothing that anyone would ever want to log.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't build chips out of this stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, gnarled up, like windswept trees that protect the rest of this island from the wind, all that other stuff, and keep the soil on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we're going into the woods.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you want to go up this direction.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so... We've got to take time to review them.
[SPEAKER_04]: We don't need to be... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you lead the guys up in this direction onto the southern side of the island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Picking your way through the scrub brush, finding the paths there, how far do you want to go?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to go all the way to the rock outcropping?
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to go to where we meet the rock outcropping, but we're still in between the bushes and stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you get back now?
[SPEAKER_02]: After...
[SPEAKER_02]: Ten minutes, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ten minutes, so it's probably gonna go back to him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you get back up into here, and you reach the base of where the cliffs start to overlook that area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably, I would say that took you guys about, let me think, 45 minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've gone about two miles to get to this area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to stop?
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't see anybody pursuing you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see the lighthouse in that area, down there, and then, of course, the lights of the city in that area.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's chill.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's talk about this, what our next move is going to be.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's get a rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't need any hits back.
[SPEAKER_02]: I could use a lot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys, basically, in the bushes, below the rocks, kind of lay low.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so let's role play.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys discuss what's happening.
[SPEAKER_04]: You should have let us get captured.
[SPEAKER_04]: Why do you think we should have got captured?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because we could have...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not gonna let him ever...
[SPEAKER_01]: He is my best friend ever in the world.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm never gonna let him get hurt.
[SPEAKER_01]: We could have gotten captured and taken two... And you two, sneaky motherfuckers, could have snuck along the way there.
[SPEAKER_01]: We could have gotten captured.
[SPEAKER_01]: I couldn't have snuck along with you guys next time.
[SPEAKER_00]: If something else like this comes along...
[SPEAKER_01]: Me and him can hang no matter what.
[SPEAKER_01]: You two sneaky motherfuckers can sneak around and sneak all your sneakness.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't sneak for shit, but I can protect my buddy no problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: So future reference, if shit goes down and we're drunk and we're having a good time and we're playing some shit up, just let us go off and get taken away.
[SPEAKER_03]: He thinks they're not after us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then you two sneaky fuckers can go along and break us out of wherever the fuck we are.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I'll keep him alive for sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: They asked for your name, and you said Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: May I express myself?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are in territory, we have never been before, where Owen knows everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen has his hands in every single pot.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, for me to announce myself being Owen, they could have been like, oh, it's just Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm just going to go along as Owen's bodyguard.
[SPEAKER_04]: And they would have disregarded it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I understand that, but when they were searching Owen's ship, I think they were going to ask.
[SPEAKER_01]: But right here, Owen is walking out of the woods and his bodyguard's got his dick in his fucking hands.
[SPEAKER_01]: Said to go get them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_04]: But when they reacted like, oh, Owen Black, and charged at him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not thinking.
[SPEAKER_00]: But then, I said to Owen to get information on whether the people around us are against Owen Black or with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which I have now- I could have been-
[SPEAKER_01]: I could have been his bodyguard next time, just so you know.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm just saying we could have done a lot of things different and that's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think the people that we were up against just now are not fans of Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're not fans of us right now very much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just gonna throw that out there.
[SPEAKER_03]: So they're from the guard, the garrison here, from the castle.
[SPEAKER_03]: How do we know it wasn't just a patrol down to go keep the peace because someone said, oh shit, there's been some people that have been killed down there and they're like, huh, alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because they searched the vessel and went right to the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but they were looking for Owen.
[SPEAKER_01]: They were going to take Owen back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen here, I was going to be his bodyguard.
[SPEAKER_01]: You two could have snuck along the way.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think they know who Owen is.
[SPEAKER_04]: And Owen's probably Owen.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, they called him Owen.
[SPEAKER_04]: They were like, oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: They said, hey, Owen Black, we want to talk to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're going to take you to our leader.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I think when they got close enough they would have been like, oh, that is not Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but that means they don't know who we are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you seen this guy perform before?
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you ever seen this man perform before?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I saw him perform today and it wasn't the best.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm skipping out there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, you put a lot of pressure on me, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_04]: Before we start moving out and doing shit, we need to find out more information.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because if we go out in the city and shit, if we got mercenaries on us from Berlin...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's too late.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything changes now.
[SPEAKER_01]: The point is now, what do we got to do now?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't go out right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: The point is now, we should go to the castle.
[SPEAKER_01]: He wanted to talk to Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to know why he wanted to talk to Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe if we parlay a little bit... Do you two want to parlay?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll parlay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can parlay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can parlay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, we can parlay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you guys think that's the best thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: You wanna parlay?
[SPEAKER_04]: I wanna parlay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you have disguises in your thing?
[SPEAKER_04]: Him and I go way back.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys know each other probably.
[SPEAKER_00]: I should have an entertainer's pack, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: You do have an entertainer's pack.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not really disguises.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have disguises, but what they are is costumes.
[SPEAKER_01]: We should go and find out what this guy's got, but I am fucking fucked right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, Kassel's over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kassel's way on the other end.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, we should go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Before anything, Tyrus, what do you and Gouge think on, do you think these guys are against Owen Black or with Owen Black?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the big question.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think Owen Black's, I don't think anybody's against him here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Against him or not.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's just running shit back and forth as a traitor.
[SPEAKER_03]: They thought he was Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would they want him, why would the prince want to talk to Owen Black?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think the only thing, if Owen signed this at all, they'd know that Owen brought us here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, and maybe that's it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So let me say something about the reaction that they had.
[SPEAKER_02]: They seemed to know who Owen Black was, but they didn't just automatically want to be violent.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right?
[SPEAKER_02]: They were like, come down here and talk to us.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's not like they were friendly either.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like their attitude was sort of like, oh, Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come here, bitch.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're gonna have a discussion about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is the deal is, why did, what's the king of the, what's the ruler?
[SPEAKER_02]: The Earl of Redshore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why did the Earl of Redshore want to talk to Owen Black?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what we need to figure out.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think Owen knows something about this lack where the, the turtle dragons and stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think he knows more than he's letting on about.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do an in-check.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do an in-check.
[SPEAKER_02]: An in-check?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I told you.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18 plus...
[SPEAKER_00]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Six dead bodies in the chart room?
[SPEAKER_02]: And Owen Black paid somebody off to kill those guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, the Earl of Redshore doesn't want that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: These guys killed six pounds.
[SPEAKER_02]: Theoretically, you notice we had your back.
[SPEAKER_01]: So keep that in mind, you little assassinating bastard.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I just had an epiphany.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why the Earl of Redshore doesn't want
[SPEAKER_00]: The murder and pillaging of his land.
[SPEAKER_00]: So why would the Earl of Redshore be friendly with Owen Black when he's the one hiring mercenaries and now there's six dead bodies in their bar and thievery amongst people going on under his nose?
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe the Earl isn't real happy that there's these man-of-war outside his fuckin' thing so nobody can do shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think the Earl is very much against...
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: They're from his country, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Man of Wars are, from his country.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a Keolander.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ew.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he is happy about this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think... We need to talk to the Earl.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we had an easy way to get there.
[SPEAKER_01]: But somebody wants to start flinging fucking arrows from the woods.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next time...
[SPEAKER_01]: You just let us go, and then you can break our ass out of jail at some point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yup.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had something, then lost it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, now we need to find our way to sneak into the Earl's house.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got that.
[SPEAKER_04]: We realize that you guys cannot sneak, so that is not on the table.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you guys want to parlay,
[SPEAKER_04]: Me and Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we gotta get all the way across this island now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sneakily.
[SPEAKER_01]: Restfully.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mostly restfully.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you guys want to parlay, you guys can go back out there.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not going to go that direction to parlay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to go to the Earl's castle.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to get into the Earl's castle and then we'll do the parlaying part.
[SPEAKER_04]: So let's take a rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to lead us in the wilderness as far as I can towards the castle.
[SPEAKER_04]: That way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Once we get close enough, let's discuss more of a plan about how we're gonna get in, how we're gonna get information, and what does that look like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or the only other thing we could do is find Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: There is that too.
[SPEAKER_03]: Owen Black wanted us killed, paid hired mercenaries to kill us.
[SPEAKER_03]: But where's he at?
[SPEAKER_03]: If they didn't find him, where's he at?
[SPEAKER_03]: They didn't seem happy with the name Owen Black, nor did they seem
[SPEAKER_03]: Immediately pissed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you know anything about... No, we need to talk to the Earl at this point.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no way Owen can be able to pay off the whole Earl of Red Shore's cavalry to go find us.
[SPEAKER_00]: No way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Earl is just a tool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen is just a tool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen's just running shit back and forth for his own gain and he's definitely working with Kane Tolley.
[SPEAKER_00]: He knows a lot about that amulet with the turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we rest and we should go speak with the Earl and... Yeah, sneak our way somehow to meet the Earl.
[SPEAKER_01]: You two are gonna go and try to gain that audience?
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't know yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta rest a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: A whole lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: I feel like if they question us, I will deny and lie.
[SPEAKER_00]: They heard Owen, I actually yelled
[SPEAKER_00]: Fuck showing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fuck going, that's what we said.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so let's go rest, because I need to heal up a lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: I like a whole... All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you may camp.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to do a long rest here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this going to be considered a long rest?
[SPEAKER_02]: If you guys want to do a long rest till morning, a long rest is eight hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: That means that at this point you would wake at 7 a.m. in the morning as the sun rises.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you guys want to say that one?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or do you want to go during night, undercover?
[SPEAKER_02]: He should be at the best health he can.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, and the thing is, as long as we give you your spells back, all of you guys will get your spells back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are we in enough where it was like, we're not like just off the beaten path a little bit, like we're just, we're covered.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you're two miles away from the path.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're in a place where, you know, somebody, you, you, if you would set up and you were keeping watch, you'd know somebody coming at you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right?
[SPEAKER_03]: We're probably more in danger of wandering monsters in this area than anyone coming across us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Snakes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Weird shit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's long rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we're about a long rest, is anybody hurt?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes!
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll keep watching.
[SPEAKER_02]: With a long rest, you get all your hit points back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Never mind.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't have to worry about this.
[SPEAKER_02]: One more question.
[SPEAKER_03]: As long as your rest is for short rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we also get back all of our short rest dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know this island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Short rest dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Our short rest dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: All come back.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll come back.
[SPEAKER_04]: I know this island well, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, but you know the shoreline well, and actually from the vantage point you are, this is the highest point.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you could see everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: But from here, you can pretty much see the layout of the entire truck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Over here is little...
[SPEAKER_02]: Misty, because the island is about eight miles long.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're two miles from that side, but you can see the castle over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you confident that if we rush through the night that you can get us undercover during morning light coming up?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I can traverse the land.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's all darkness over this way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Some industry up in the hills area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Most of the people live down here on the shore, the North Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nobody's going to know that we're there.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're good.
[SPEAKER_01]: All my hells are back.
[SPEAKER_01]: All my spells are back.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I know with my intelligence is that Monmurg cool with Redshore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they allianced under the Sea of Principalities?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so this is the history.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Earl of Redshore is a vassal of Duke of Gratzel who is at war with the Monmurgans, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: The Earl of Redshore is the guy that owns the land where all these merchants are being corralled.
[SPEAKER_02]: So at the very least, the Earl of Redshore is allied with your enemies.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, in the past, there hasn't been a lot of animosity between Monmurg and the Earl of Redshore.
[SPEAKER_02]: But he owes his allegiance to Duke of Razzle.
[SPEAKER_02]: And those men of war out in the bay,
[SPEAKER_02]: Those are his men.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, they're Gretzolian men, so he's at least saying yay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, he might not be happy that this is happening in his properties, his area, but you don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he's definitely alive with Duke of Gretzel and Kane Tolley.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you don't know about Kane Tolley.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kane Tolley's from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, he's not from Monmurg, he's from Toli, which is part of the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's this weird marriage going on between the Toli and Gratzel, and you don't know how the Earl Richard is evolved.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are me and Merrick and Tyrus all wearing like
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it look like we're from Monmurg with our Navy uniforms?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, he's wearing Ranger stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: But me and Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_02]: You, kind of.
[SPEAKER_02]: The armor you wear, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: But to be honest with you guys,
[SPEAKER_02]: This is all kind of a mixed up deal.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like you're wearing marine scale mail.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're wearing a brass plate you took off a dead hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're wearing leather armor, subtle leather armor.
[SPEAKER_02]: You look like mercenaries.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like you're like, oh, these are marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not wearing colors.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge looks like
[SPEAKER_02]: A mercenary scumbag, you know?
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy looks like a pilot, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I just want to make sure that this is on record.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I'm going to turn to Gouge and I'm going to say, I know that you go alone, but just so you know, you can tell there, we got your back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's obviously in your best interest to have my back.
[SPEAKER_03]: But, we're all in this shit together.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus, Gouge is the way it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have Gouge's back as much as Gouge has our backs.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys want to take a long rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we take a break break here?
[SPEAKER_01]: We can take a break break.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here are some things that I want to ask, and I'll ask each person.